das ist wirklich faszinierend es gab ja
schon länger vermutungen das leben wir
auf der erde schon kurz nach ihrer
entstehung entstanden ist schon öfter
wurden micro fossilen also versteinerte
mikroben gefunden doch diese funde waren
nicht eindeutig es gab zweifel daran ob
es wirklich fossilien oder irgendetwas
anderes war der beweis dass es wirklich
fossilien sind wäre spektakulär solche
funde während ein weiterer hinweis
darauf dass es nur noch eine frage der
zeit ist bis wir außerirdisches leben
finden dann würde leben nämlich nahezu
überall auch unter extremen bedingungen
entstehen
und jetzt ist es tatsächlich passiert
gänsehaut ein forschungsteam hat die
wollen wirklich ältesten nachweise für
leben auf unserem heimatplaneten
eindeutig als solche bestätigt um welche
lebensformen es sich bei den fossilien
handelt was das für zukünftige mars
mission bedeutet und ob diese entdeckung
tatsächlich endlich die antwort auf die
große frage ist wann der große prozess
des lebens seinen anfang nahm jetzt in
klicks um science-fiction herzlich
willkommen ach ja und nachdem ich das
letzte video online gestellt habe ist
etwas wirklich ihres passiert mehr dazu
am ende
erst vor kurzem haben wir von einem
sensationsfund berichtet damals ging es
um spuren aus altem gestein in kanada
die wohl auch von lebenden organismen
stammen könnten die vielleicht ältesten
fossilien auf der erde ihr alter 3,77
bis zu 4,2 milliarden jahre im vergleich
dazu unsere erde entstand vor rund 4,5
milliarden jahren also nur kurze zeit
davor die erkenntnis kurz nach der
entstehung der erde entstand wohl auch
leben auf ihr doch einen kleinen haken
an dieser story dann gibt es doch wenn
der endgültige nachweis dass es sich
hierbei eindeutig um erster lebensspuren
handelt der konnte bislang noch nicht so
100 prozentiger sicherheit bestätigt
werden doch der direkte nachweis von
leben ist jetzt einem forschungsteam aus
los angeles bei ähnlich alten
fossilienfunden gelungen konkret geht es
hier um gestein das bereits 1993 im
westen australiens entdeckt wurde
bei den feinen verästelungen und linien
mustern wurden rund 3,5 milliarden als
soll es sich also tatsächlich um
organisches material handeln das im
gestein eingeschlossen wurde anders als
ihr entdecker welchen job bezweifelten
andere forscherinnen und forscher
weltweit seine interpretation dass es
sich dabei um die ältesten spuren des
lebens auf der erde handelt doch genau
das will shop zusammen mit seinem team
jetzt bewiesen haben
bei den untersuchungen hat das us
forschungsteam erstmals die
isotopenzusammensetzung der promx
analysiert und zwar mit einem see kennt
sekundär ionen massenspektrometern bei
der analyse von organischen material ist
vor allem das typische verhältnis der
kohlenstoff isotope 12 und 13
entscheidend und das ergebnis ist
sensationell
denn es spiegelt genau diejenigen
isotopenzusammensetzung wieder die man
beim mikrobiellen lebensform erwarten
würde dazu mit dem schopf das c 12 zu 10
13 verhältnis ist charakteristisch für
die biologie unterschiedlicher
organismen und jetzt haltet euch fest
das forschungsteam weiß sogar um welche
konkreten lebensformen es sich bei
diesen fossilien gehandelt haben muss
und zwar um primitive aber vielfältig
und gruppen von
gewesen und es wird ziemlich genau
beispielsweise bakterien die die sonne
zur energiegewinnung genutzt haben
gamma proteo bakterien die methan
konsumieren sowie sogenannte russian das
sind quasi uhr bakterien die das gas
methan produzieren
ihr wisst vielleicht was genau dieses
gas die atmosphäre von damals ausgemacht
hat neben bereits ausgestorbenen
organismen konnte das forschungsteam um
william shop tatsächlich auch
lebensformen identifizieren die mikroben
von heute extrem ähnlich sind für den us
wissenschaftler ist damit endlich der
riesige streit um irdische lebensspuren
geklärt das ergebnis seiner untersuchung
nämlich dass bereits vor 3,5 milliarden
jahren unterschiedliche gruppen von
mikroorganismen auf der erde lebten
lässt schopf zufolge nur ein fazit zu
das leben muss schon einige zeit davor
seinen anfang genommen haben
das ergebnis ist bedeutend denn es zeigt
nicht nur wie lange es bereits leben auf
unserem heimatplaneten gibt sondern auch
wie schnell es sich unter extremen
bedingungen entwickelt hat wir haben ja
hier schon öfter darüber berichtet aber
auch diese untersuchung macht mal wieder
deutlich dass selbst unter den
krassesten extrembedingungen egal ob
trocken kalt oder heiß leben entsteht
und sich zudem auch noch
weiterentwickelt und ihr könnt es euch
denken nur eine schlussfolgerung daraus
macht sinn nahezu auf allen exoplaneten
mit wasser in der habitablen zone ist
die wahrscheinlichkeit jetzt extrem groß
leben zu entdecken
wow genauso wie auf dem mars denn ich
bin der überzeugung die unterschiede vom
roten planeten zu den lebensbedingungen
an manchen orten der erde wie etwa der
atacama wüste sind absolut minimal wie
unfassbar großartig wäre es also wenn
wir irgendwann die entdeckung machen
würden dass das ganze universum nur so
voll ist mit leben gänsehaut tour
denn er als erstes neues zu diesem thema
zum thema außerirdische erfahren wollt
dann meldet euch bei vox app an
hier ist der link dann erfahrt ihr vor
allen anderen vom neuesten video
garantie ihr könnt direkt
themenvorschläge machen oder andere
ideen vorschlagen der direkte draht zu
mir einfach hier draufklicken gestern
name schon achtung festhalten 1000
gemacht und ich habe wirklich jede
nachricht beantwortet ja und hier geht
es weiter mit dafür
klicken fossilien geben hinweise auf
außerirdisches leben ja da war es alles
noch nicht so klar
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran